You
know
how eighty three live. The eighty four the cell team which
is used to would use it in
the fall no easy to lead it will come out maybe three donate
if you want to relive the rule or sign.
And you
said you were good before you married a New
Labour's
re-employed that day every day in your memory going back when he was known for
a steely
EPS it's your long neck pain quote I
say to him about that yet.
Oh nothing to folly is a disease course where would
that be down low his chest out back in
the world still does have to start anew even you
know
it's still a plan ation backdated. And we're back in
that town a nation that will let my father
find the plantation with the high price tag is there any way that I know that
guy
has many names.
You know and when he says.
Jared he says when he sees it I said you know the fries that owner that's highly
connected and all these people a year you tell them. On Blue
is this a good song really and Bush was all done it
was wrong that second as many.
That lead him on the Think of the day when you go in there
too but I didn't loan seconds in that Penny
ship's wireless where real
days after we moved. LULU.
And I think it's plenty. We moved from there. They were my
lovely and we move them they have to pay for any.
And the
well when you get married human to be willing.
You know for
being hurt.
Langley and nice.
Because a call so
that the whole songs around Akko not dead and why we used to come up. Why do
they
will then little is being made with the purpose of
using for.
Well it was anything or anybody losing and that it was.
They had to
write the down gently.
Afterward Don't you is a nice name the these these
amazingly as it was the
room where they live post down by my count of the around the
common area that was the last hours a
lead. To
three
feet from stones and to still want to recover our home and in with
the
digital memory that when that will.
We still have not the heart
on. Pentecost on the memories
and
fan who were there for it to give ALWAYS A us.
In that house over there.
Plainly a when I lose looking to still with
you find those here and post always little me three would
need good advice and leave here called I have to come from
for
amounts they won't pay the call Rocky he'll. They call that
the rocky deal now. D.S. and now to come up here and you will make
the rest of the why did you go
to the. The
you in
Thomas Mallon as
a human is
I.
Grew it
about when I played.
It involved a good
deal that moved up
here Bill Clinton who delivered the when women
bring the members
of
Miami really come up.
In the banking and.
The ground rules and pressure the whole
thing
to go. I guess he must have been no.
Need to move on with the practice.
He really
did. When
they lived
whose postmaster.
Ligeti no congesting Kanchan.
Yeah that was what the two of the move attention
were here when he was running when I
came back
the same thing you're going to.
But it was my
last eighty percent out being Muslims and don't you mean
the news is no longer the most going to movies on
T.V. They use terms like ours and by the
way why games are abstracted camped on this one who is
very all of that group Claire clean all thing they use the campfire
thing and you say I feel I was I'm going to have feelings and all that I read
was just a private Oh all knew it was all cleared up they up.
And they would hail all kind of different kind of animals and things
there that's really clay own back pain.
And they come and they are determined in covering language might that arise
again with kids on the way to and that the timeline for just going to it
is they eat B. C.
and put in a home where we said to the cause then you have cancer or would
you rather then they would get to far from different places and you would camp be
unable we mean they were two or three nights before we move on going
forward we were right here in this
NG You were living in a half
long time running film that is forty five
years ago.
Boning this guy see again
the hero's first car you have so.
I don't remember the causeway so real that.
Here around first
are you. Where was it
and would be
homeless were having the background they have
a car say Rand they're going to say hey come the times you
that look at this I see.
You. Yeah.
This is some of some of the homes. Why don't the
policy process. This
is a really little airplane
to kill
them freedom coming from
all our rights.
When this
community front of their own label said one
of
the things almost a
very plainly playing
patient will be deceived
by Big Oil I
say Yes I don't know about them people
who did tell Maison police when
they got on but you think
clearly but I know you
don't like it was no one would call the police take care
and
then sell it but you
go. And use the cowards. So many of these
have to have seen the parallax while
you live
here and then your buff to do some more you go to prison I think
will bring
down magnesium all these two
years then you. You say well you are here when this
green
Iraqi man Brian.
That's
who they are.
Queer is a loaded question of over from our friends at the next
crossing from you where you live you have
your own no I didn't I didn't have to
will hire you the all right I will NEVER I'm constantly
in this school because it's our rule right in front of
our rather proud though I call it knowing where
you want a chair. All right all alone now and me.
We will grow up in
from and Haley's for yours then we had to have a
checkbook right Dave alone amazes and there where we went to church
and Sunday
schooling in the wrong way we had to walk
there. That little boy didn't have didn't have a
chance there the him you see you have a chip salesman. We will go in
the school as it was at school then you build a church sayer.
And it shifted.
My mother and father was there was they were our
C.M.E. that was a C.M.E. a chit that
we were five not men congregate. You know and
it led them to Methodist to
this and then I later on this when the New Years come along why build
this in the
church like you call it had
Africa as a mess. And that after Mrs G.
is like in the deal and they are you see the way girls
are
sent me to a Methodist church right down in
the AN ACTUAL.
World. Who are.
You said you that use the lack of god from the Acts
and gossip are you. We're
going to kill
or we'll.
After we moved here.
He still was out with up. But then we got in touch this.
Got to Brown he was going he was and so I was I don't know how long he was into so it was you then.
We used to dock a maximum right on. Until he come in and
got to practice
on medical here in down the leeward seem like
old people move around here went to Dr Brant where he was out cold
and then he was do you think he could come he would come any time you call him in a car one
night he would call you call Dr Brown he was a
it's wherever
we go anywhere the sound of
that they would do
like lovely you
from then on then tell you couldn't see who's alleged Ricky
a
hero and he called his wife and yet of the little
blue main room he deal with Whoa whoa whoa whoa he no we
just like more his
spirits. He came over here to have any S. me he said I'm going to be
in the hood to do to
like have navy see. He a dental practice all
night and somebody out in that rank said Amanda thank
a Colin and he said You must've been hastily and he ran
into this other call. And
then we asked Danny didn't Gates ask a don't know was cooking what it and
where he came back to my mother was a company
town few years. It's all about the macula not the only thing
you know when I. So he's
going to see that wreck us and also to.
Lisa
he will go and his daughter came
here like a
bomb in our
activities that I just practiced so may have been somewhere ranks then
I can tell you yes he got Omar No that I didn't go up there to make me nervous.
To medium and he was trying to say let's go today bad now I have a decent
day. Not a go get up to leave
you. Got
to have a cheerleader. T.N..
Can't you see until fairly
seldom ever that no one in the C.L.R. no. I live in
Oakley. But I
don't want to dig then that.
The
A only ever I knew. I got nailed.
On leaving town with
little Yeah a little brown won me a ride on a level headed leader that right
after gets him done
it he called his one here.
Ronnie and both dad
and Ronnie in New York.
Lonnie and some of the Iranian people anymore
you really really. Well if.
The get one is with you and
I both Never.
Leave you here. We're here now released four years.
Barassi only got to go that old Ryssdal more
what they did
he warned me of being alone with our legal
ladies this half is the same they
have to learn it you and I read it to come back they will hear some
witty comeback you know what is coming back home and if I didn't leave
here infallibly so muddled into your own that you
included come here and egg like
you did you call them back
home so I promised him I'd do my
B. B. sit alone.
You say you did.
Yes I know I don't exist
for the in the end in Nowhere
I think it will be right. As would
go up in handcuffs along the lane out of our way every day
you too little class.
There were details. That's a legal mess to deal in Reno and
got good results from it too.